أعط المتظاهرين عمدة موسكو سيرجي
سوبيانين 2017 موسكو
يبلغ من العمر سبعمائة وسبعين سنة
ذكرى ميلادنا القديمة وعاصمتنا دائما
يجتمع في الأعمال التي تتكاثر و
ومجد وإنجازات موسكو
هو الخلق والتنمية
موسكو هي رياض الأطفال الحديثة و
أفضل المدارس في موسكو
إنه دواء عالي الجودة وبأسعار معقولة
موسكو
هذه ساحات فناء مريحة وحدائق جميلة
موسكو سريعة وموثوقة
النقل العام
موسكو هي احترام للقيمة الماضية
حاضر
والثقة في العاصمة المستقبلية موسكو
روسيا العظمى
أفضل مدينة على وجه الأرض
يا هلا
[موسيقى]
تعلن نقابات عمال موسكو اليوم
تضامنها مع جميع العمال
في الكفاح من أجل العمل اللائق والاجتماعي
عدالة
شعار اتحاد نقابات عمال موسكو
وحدة تضامن حقوق الانسان
المخاض نهنئه في اليوم الأول من ذهابهم
في طوافتنا من عمال مدينة موسكو
ولا سيما الذين يكرمون عاليا
ألقاب أبطال العمل الاشتراكي و
أبطال العمل في الاتحاد الروسي
الرجل العامل أساس مجتمعنا
النقابات العمالية تدافع عن العمل اللائق و
من أجل التنمية المستقرة للطلب النقابي
الحد الأدنى للأجور لكل مستوى
لا تقل عن أجر المعيشة
تحديد مبلغ معاش الدولة
ضمان الحق في لائقة
تعزيز الاتحادات هدف الشيخوخة
بدوام كامل
ظروف عمل آمنة
تنفيذ تشريعات العمل
تحيا الأول من مايو العالم
هتاف صديق
لكن
[موسيقى]
راتب وظيفي لائق
تحالفات الحياة روك من أجل حياة كريمة
نقابة عمال بشرية من أجل عادلة
لسياسة اجتماعية قوية خارج المجالات
لا يوجد تخفيض في الأجور الاجتماعية
يضمن شيخوخة محترمة
معاش لائق للأطفال الحق في الراحة و
التعافي
النقابة هي حمايتك في النقابة هي ملكك
الخضوع ل
[موسيقى]
لكن
نهنئ المتظاهرين في عيد العمال
أعمدة عمال مدينة موسكو و
خاصة الذين تم تكريمهم
ألقاب أبطال العمل الاشتراكي و
أبطال العمل في الاتحاد الروسي
الرجل العامل أساس مجتمعنا
النقابات العمالية تدافع عن العمل اللائق و
من أجل التنمية المستدامة في استطلاعات الرأي
[تصفيق]
إنهم أصدقاء
أهلا بك من قبل رئيس موسكو
اتحاد نقابات العمال ميخائيل أنتونتسيف
مرحبا عزيزي سكان موسكو
مرحبا تنظيف العاصمة
يشرفني أن أرحب
لكم نيابة عن اتحاد موسكو
النقابات وأتمنى لكم التوفيق
اليوم العالمي للتضامن
عطلة الربيع والعمل
يا هلا
[تصفيق]
اليوم ما هي المطبوعة من الافتخار بها
هنا على ريد سكوير الناس الذين
افعلها بنفسك
قلوب وعقول مدينتنا أكثر
أكثر جمالا
أحق ببلدنا الجبار
كلمات اغتصاب تعيش طويلا لا يقهر
في صحتك لرجل العمل
[تصفيق]
كل ما فعلناه بفضل
كبار السن وقدامى المحاربين الآن 6 كلمات
قدامى المحاربين في العمل والحرب كل ما نحن و
يتم القيام به للأطفال كثيرا
سعادة
حياة كريمة والرغبة في الخلق معا
دفعة واحدة تعطي الجديد والجديد
انتصارات
يعيش رجل العمل المجد
إجازة سعيدة لروسيا أيها الرفاق الأعزاء
رجل حقيقي
هذه
والرفاق والترحيب بكم
رئيس اتحاد المستقلين
نقابات عمال روسيا ميخائيل شماكوف
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
فتح الاصدقاء مرحبا ايها الرفاق
عطلة سعيدة لك مع يوم عطلة لدينا
التضامن الدولي للعمال
اليوم يحتفل هذا العيد بالمزيد
أكثر من 140 دولة في العالم ومسألة كيفية الدخول
من تضامن عمال العالم وأنا
أنا دائما أستجيب لتضامن العمال
العالم في التايغا واحد من العدالة
جلبت
في جميع البلدان يسمى
العولمة التي
ولد ما يكفي من الملابس الجميلة
لكن مع ذلك يجلبون إلى جميع البلدان
تقلل الأجور من الفقر
الاعتداء على حقوق العمال في هذا و
هناك تضامن مع جميع البلدان العاملة
كل الدول تظهر رفضها
لذلك من خلال سياسة مماثلة اليوم في
روسيا نحتفل بهذا اليوم
تقليديا في صالوناتنا
أكثر من مليوني ونصف المليون مواطن
النشطاء النقابيين الروس عطلة
بدأت في الشرق الأقصى في كامتشاتكا
على سخالين
في فلاديفوستوك كان هناك 30 40 1000
المسيرات والمواكب هي الأكثر عظمة
مرت المواكب فوق الجسر المثبت بالكابلات
فلاديفوستوك أين
وسار 45 ألف متظاهر
باستثناء ساحاتهم وشوارعهم على هذا
جسر فوق الخليج بالطبع لدينا
100000 مظاهرة في موسكو
سوف تساهم في هذا العيد
ما هي عطلة العيد
مظاهرة مظاهرة قوتنا
منظمتنا لدينا
تكافل
إرادتنا لتحقيق الأهداف التي نحن
مجموعة والمطلوبة للامتثال
حكومات جميع المناطق
حكومة روسيا ، أي جديرة
أجور لائقة
حياة كريمة وسنحققها
من أجل أن يحدث هذا هناك بالفعل نوبات ولكن
أنها صغيرة جدا
الآن ومع ذلك نحن نحاول
الكتلة الاقتصادية المالية 1
الحكومة الروسية لفرض جديد
ضرائب الرسوم الجديدة
قواعد OSAGO الجديدة غير العادلة
رسوم جديدة غير عادلة جديدة و
فواتير المياه والكهرباء غير العادلة
خدمات
لكن هذا يحدث على خلفية عدم رفع كذلك
في بعض الأحيان وخفض الأجور لا نفعل ذلك
دعنا نقول هذا
هذا هو صوتنا الصلب في صحتك
[تصفيق]
اليوم في إجازتنا هناك العديد من الأطفال
تحية لجميع الشباب الذين هم معا
معنا
بالطبع قدامى المحاربين لدينا بالطبع
العاملين في قطاعاتنا الأساسية
الأنشطة في كل من موسكو وروسيا في
بشكل عام وخاصه وتهنئتي علي
عطلة اليوم
أطفالنا هم أطفال من المدرسة
مقاعد المدرسة من سنوات الدراسة
شارك وسوف تتحمل هذا
التقليد يستمر مع عطلة لك
أيها الرفاق الأعزاء في العالم
في صحتك الرفاق
[تصفيق]
النقابات تقف من أجل العدالة
الحياة الكريمة والازدهار
سكان موسكو مع عمال العاصمة
أعمدة احتفالية من المتظاهرين تذهب و
النقابات العمالية بالقرب من موسكو
معًا يمكننا فعل المزيد على الصفحة الرئيسية
ساحات البلد ويمر العمال
سكة حديد موسكو مستحيلة
تمثل أكبر حضرية
حاضرة
بدون محطات جميلة عالية السرعة
قطارات وقطارات الركاب
حمل الملايين من الناس موضع ترحيب
عمال السكك الحديدية في موسكو ومنطقة موسكو
يا هلا
[تصفيق]
عمود ترحيب من موسكو Electro
اتحاد تجاري
اجازة سعيدة لك يا اصدقائي الأعزاء
العمال المتظاهرين بريدوه
الرعاية الصحية في موسكو
الطب هو المعدات الحديثة و
العلاجات المتطورة التي تعزز
توافر رعاية المرضى الخارجيين و
زيادة عدد التكنولوجيا العالية
عمليات
فمن اليقظة والرعاية والأطباء
مبيعات الممرضات
متوسط ​​العمر المتوقع لسكان موسكو
فوق 77 سنة
أعلى درجة على الإطلاق
نقابة عمال المدينة
الرعاية الصحية في موسكو لتقف على
بناء مستشفيات وعيادات جديدة
رفع رواتب الأطباء و
الممرضات
أطباء موسكو لديهم عالمة اجتماعية
الحالة
صحة الناس قبل كل شيء عزيزي
أصدقاء يوم تضامن دولي سعيد
العمال أهنئكم رئيس
دوما مدينة موسكو
أليكسي شابوشنيكوف
مرحبا موسكو ، مرحبا روسيا
اليوم نحن هنا على المنطقة الحمراء
تجمع المربعات لإظهار أن الجميع
نحن قريبًا بطاقات أننا جميعًا عاملون
اليوم في عاصمتنا في مدينتك
بغض النظر
تظهر مؤسسة جديدة
أماكن العمل
موسكو مدينة دوما مع
عمال
يؤجل نفسه كان مهمة مثل تومي صحيح
راتب لائق حياة كريمة
عطلة الحيوانات المنوية
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
نرحب بكم في المربع الأحمر
الرياضيون الأولمبيون في موسكو
أبطال وأبطال العالم
مجد وفخر الرياضة الوطنية
في عام 2016 في الأولمبي
هيدراس في البرازيل في المنتخب الوطني
كانت الفرق الروسية 88 من سكان موسكو
لقد قدموا مساهمة كبيرة في النجاح
أداء
منتخباتنا الوطنية فازت بـ 11
الميداليات الذهبية للفريق الروسي
موسكو هي عاصمة الأبطال الأولمبيين
موسكو هي أفضل الرياضات
أسلوب حياة الرياضة البنية التحتية أربعة
مليون سكان موسكو غدا سيكونون
أكثر لأنه في باحات الحدائق
الساحات والصالات الرياضية والملاعب
سكان موسكو لديهم كل فرصة
الأنشطة الترفيهية والرياضية
المزيد من الرياضة
المزيد من القوة ، المزيد من الفرح أكثر
الصحة
كلمات لرياضيين موسكو تستحق
استمرارا للتقاليد المنتصرة
هتافات الرياضة المحلية
[موسيقى]
سطح يمر عبر المربع الأحمر
موظفي الإسكان والخدمات المجتمعية
مزارع في موسكو
الإسكان والخدمات المجتمعية هي منطقة حيوية في المدينة
مسؤولة عن الحرارة والضوء في المنازل
سكان موسكو لنقاء الجبن من الطرق
لجمال الشوارع والمتنزهات فهي ضخمة
مقدار العمل الذي بنجاح
التعامل مع نصف مليون عامل الإسكان والخدمات المجتمعية
ستالين اليوم في الأنهار في صفوف
المتظاهرين العاملين في الدماغ من الأنف
فائدة المياه ديكا موس رفع جسر الضوء أ
ها هي الخطوة اللعينة لأنف المصحح
أنف ووتر الشرق طريق جسر شاقة
الطرق والمرافق الأخرى
العواصم في pervomaisky kolomna
العاملين بمنطقة إسكان المؤسسات
شركات الإدارة والمقاولون
منظمات الإسكان والخدمات المجتمعية في موسكو تعمل
نوعيًا وموثوقًا بدون حوادث و
الحوادث في منازل موسكو دائما
تأكل
الماء الساخن 32 لراحة صناديق الرمل و
راحة
يرحب بكم أصدقائي الأعزاء
رئيس النقابة
عمال بلدية موسكو سيرجي
أسمر
أعزائي سكان موسكو اليوم أحييهم
موظفي الإسكان والخدمات المجتمعية
الاقتصاد وتحسين العاصمة
القوس المنخفض لمن صنعت أيديهم
موسكو نظيفة مريحة
مدينة جميلة صالحة للعيش فيها
اعتاد سكان موسكو على الراحة عندما
من الصنابير دائمًا تجعيد الشعر الساخن والبارد
الماء عندما تومض الثريات مشرقة
يمر الضوء على كل موقد غاز
يناسب التنظيف المستمر للغاز والشوارع
الأصدقاء الأعزاء المريحين هذا هو لك
عمل نكران الذات عظيم لك
شكرا لك أنا فخور بأنك عهدت إلي
حماية حقوقك ومصالحك نعم لدينا
لا تزال هناك عيوب هناك صعوبات
مشاكل الأمن الوظيفي
هناك مشاكل في الأجور
حماية العمل
لكنني متأكد من أن نقابات العمال في موسكو
جنبا إلى جنب مع رابطة أرباب العمل و
ستفعل حكومة المدينة كل شيء
ممكن لرفاهية سكان موسكو
النقابات تطالب
العمل اللائق بأجور لائقة
حياة جديرة لكل سكان موسكو
قد العمل
[تصفيق]
تحيا أول مايو أورال
[موسيقى]
المقياس الصحيح
تحسين المدينة 2017 جديد
أكثر من 80 شوارع العاصمة على
سيعود الترام إلى بؤرة تفير الاستيطانية و
سيأخذ طائر النوء مكانه مرة أخرى
ثورة مكسيم جوركي
الراحة والراحة في العودة و
حلقة شارع
منطقة جديدة للمشاة ستربط لوبيانكا
مع متحف إلينسكي بوليتكنيك
الكرات بالقرب من هيكل المسيح المخلص و
متحف بوشكين سيكون به مساحة أكبر
للراحة والمشي في حديقة البنوك
ساحر المعرفة ملاهي المناظر الطبيعية
وغيرها من مناطق المتنزهات في
في الحمض النووي في وسط موسكو ، على مرمى حجر من
الكرملين
سيتم افتتاح أفضل حديقة في العالم Zaryadye
برنامج رأس المال يكتسب زخما
تجديدات المنزل في عام 2017 ستكون
استبدلت تماما منتهية الصلاحية
اتحاد المصاعد البلدي المتقادم
عمال
يدعم مخططات التجميل
موسكو
نحن من أجل حياة كريمة
مدينة جميلة نحن من خلف البارجة و
مناطق مخصصة للمشاة لتوفير الراحة والراحة فيها
تم إصلاح منازلنا وساحاتنا
مساكن عالية الجودة وفي الوقت المحدد
يتلقى سكان موسكو مساكن عالية الجودة وخدمات مجتمعية
العاملين في الصناعة بأجور لائقة و
ظروف عمل آمنة
عطلة سعيدة أيها الأصدقاء الأعزاء
يا هلا
[موسيقى]
يستمر الموكب الاحتفالي في العمود
المتعلمين
يرحب بكم أصدقائي الأعزاء
نائب رئيس مجلس إدارة موسكو
نقابة عمال الشعب
التعليم والعلوم
كونستانتين بالفعل في كين صباح الخير
سكان موسكو
أصدقاء صباح الخير ، مساء الخير عزيزي
الزملاء هذا العام كنا ننتظر عيد العمال
كما لم تطول ابدا و سكينر الغناء العمل
شعرنا به
لم يكن في عجلة من امرنا وكان رمزي جدا
ما بالضبط لهذه الأعياد
اتحد الربيع والعمل مع العطلة
أصدقاء الربيع والعمل
فقط نعم التعليم هو الأكبر
منظمة نقابية في روسيا
الاتحادات
منظمة مدينة موسكو
يوحد حوالي 300 ألف عضو
الاتحاد وعمود البرد
اتحاد التعليم
في مستعمرتنا اليوم
رئيس المنظمات التعليمية
المعلمين والمربين والمعلمين و
الطلاب والشراكة الاجتماعية
واحترام الحقوق النقابية
المنظمات هي مؤسستنا
تفاعل الأصدقاء الأعزاء معنا
نظام التعليم هناك مبدأ
تريد أن تبدأ في كسب المزيد
يظهر نتائج جيدة
إذا كنت بحاجة إلى المساعدة والدعم
قطع الخضار في الاتحاد اليوم في 95
النسبة المئوية للمنظمات التعليمية
هناك الجماعية القائمة
العقود ومهمة جعل ظروف العمل
أجور آمنة
الافتتاح الموضوعي معرض العمل
ذو قيمة
مجال يضم آلاف المعلمين اليوم
المشاركة في برامجنا الاجتماعية
إعادة تأهيل الرياضة الترفيهية
لدينا رمي volod 3 ديكس الشباب
معلمون
سيولد أكثر من شخص في العام الماضي
ألف 100 طفل وهم كل أسرة
حصلوا على دعم مالي من
النقابات العمالية الأصدقاء الأعزاء
وحدة قوتنا تأتي الانضمام
اتحادنا
الاتحاد معنا تصبح أقوى
يوم الاجازة
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
في العام الماضي ، أخذت مدارس موسكو
ارتفاع جديد في مستوى غرفة القراءة
ومحو الأمية الرياضية
الطلاب من بين العشرة الأوائل في العالم
150 مدرسة في موسكو من بين 500
أفضل المدارس في روسيا
فاز 700 من سكان موسكو و
الفائزين في أولمبياد عموم روسيا
و 9 من ألمع موسكو وأكثرها موهبة
حصل الرجال على الميدالية الذهبية في المسابقة الدولية
أولمبياد لتلاميذ المدارس
نحن فخورون بتعليم العاصمة
مدرسين موهوبين وناجحين
الخريجين
هذه ملاعب مدرسية ورياضية جديدة
الملاعب هي أفضل رياض أطفال في العالم
هذا هو مصدر قلق خاص للأطفال ذوي الإعاقة
هو أجر لائق وعالي
هيبة المعلمين النقابية للعمال
التعليم يتطلب زيادة
تمويل المدارس ورياض الأطفال
الاستثمار في التعليم هو أفضل استثمار في
مستقبل موسكو وروسيا موسكو
المدارس
أحدث المعلومات
تقنية
كتاب مدرسي
وتربية المواطنين وتثقيف الوطنيين
عمل المعلم
بشكل عام وهتافات الاحترام
الطلاب والمعلمين بشكل مجيد
نقابات عمال الجامعات الحضرية في موسكو الطلب
زيادة المنح الاجتماعية ل
الطلاب المحتاجين
التوسع في المنح الحضرية
برنامج الطالب
المشاريع الحكومية المشاركة
موسكو لتطوير العلاقات مع المدارس أمس
طالب اليوم مشارك
طالب غد للتخزين
السفر الكامل في الأماكن العامة
المواصلات
المزيد من الفرص للطلاب
الرياضة والثقافة مساحة أكبر ل
تنفيذ مبادرات الشباب
التهاني للمعلمين و
علم
مع عطلة الربيع والعمل
يا هلا
[موسيقى]
أصدقائي الأعزاء في عام 2017 يصادف
25 عاما كنقابات عمالية في موسكو
اختتمت الثلاثية الأولى
اتفاقية شراكة اجتماعية مع
أرباب العمل وحكومة موسكو
كل هذه السنوات ، حددت شراكتنا
الرفاه الاجتماعي للعاصمة معًا
أبقينا البطالة عند الحد الأدنى
ساعد مستوى الموقع آلاف الأشخاص في العثور عليه
وظيفة جديدة معًا قمنا بحل مشكلات النمو
أجور
سعى مكان لزيادة المعاشات و
الفوائد معا
احتفظ بنظام فريد للأطفال
بقية معا خلق الظروف ل
نحن
قاتلوا ضد استيلاء المهاجم
شركات الانتعاش
عدالة العمل
الجماعات وأصحابها واليوم
رغم كل الصعوبات والمشاكل
يظهر اقتصاد موسكو
نمو قوي في عام 2016
تجاوز الاستثمار 1 و 7 أعشار
تريليون روبل ، سجل رقما قياسيا
مؤشرات عبر تاريخ الحديث
روسيا اليوم النقابات و
رجال الأعمال بحاجة إلى الدعم
الصانع المحلي يعيش في
تنتج روسيا شراء روسيا
الروسية نطالب بتحسين الجودة
التعليم المهني في الجامعات و
في الكلية نطالب بتضخم أقل
والائتمان المتاح
نطالب بقمع غير قانوني بصرامة
الهجرة
لا يوجد مكان للمهاجرين غير الشرعيين في موسكو لهؤلاء
هناك
لا عودة إلى الحصص النقابية لحمايتك
النقابة وجلست
يا هلا
شاركت قوات المظاهرة العمال
المؤسسات الصناعية في العاصمة
صناعة موسكو الحديثة
هذه رؤوس براقة وأيدي ذهبية
المهندسين الموهوبين العمال الأذكياء
إنه استثمار عالي التقنية
إعادة المعدات التقنية
تنافسية وفريدة من نوعها
المنتجات التي تجد
المشتري بعيدًا عن روسيا
صنع في موسكو مع علامة
جودة أعمدة الأعياد اليوم
منظمة المؤسسة العمالية
صناعة الطيران في موسكو
جزء من قافلة عمال الروس
شركة بناء الطائرات ميج إم إم
تحية سيارة موسكو تقف على
سميت المؤسسة على اسم تشيرنيشيف
مجمع الطيران المسمى
مصنع هليكوبتر موسكو سميت بعد
اميال
الشركات لا معهد البوليب المسمى بعد
جوكوفسكي وأكثر
تكريم قدامى المحاربين بينكم
ممثلي عمال الصناعة
هناك سلالات كثيرة في شريعة المتظاهرين
شباب الطيران الجبار الحديث
يقوي القدرة الدفاعية للدولة
ويربط مع خيوط غير مرئية لدينا
بلد ضخم
لطالما كانت صناعة الطيران
بمثابة قاطرة تنمية البلاد
ابتهاج بناة الطيران في روسيا
لكن
[موسيقى]
مرحبا بالنائب
رئيس اتحاد موسكو
الصناعيين ورجال الأعمال
أرباب العمل ماريا فيلينا والأصدقاء
في الواقع ربع قرن
نقابات أرباب العمل والسلطة والذنب
مصالح تطوير الإنتاج
كلية الهندسة التي تهم الشباب
المهن التقنية وذوي الياقات الزرقاء
ليس موسكو
مركز ابتكار حديث و
ظروف العمل الآمنة و
ثقة الشباب في العيش و
أنت بحاجة للعمل في روسيا نعم نحن متحدون
لأننا نكرم التاريخ ونتذكر ذلك
تجزئة دمرت الحضارات و
الصداقة والتضامن ساعدا دائما
بناء دولة قوية عزيزي
أصدقاء كل أولئك الذين يصنعون المخاض بشكل جيد و
كلام مدينتنا مع اجازة لك
الثقة في المستقبل و
قد الاستقرار في العالم العمل
[تصفيق]
عمود من العمال يسير إلى الميدان
شركات مجمع الدفاع
صناعة بناء السفن
هندسة إلكترونيات الراديو والضوء
صناعة أعمدة عيد العمال
عمال المجمع الصناعي الزراعي
موسكو
نرحب بالعامل الجاد الأكبر
مصانع الألبان واللحوم
مصانع الحلويات والمخابز
منتجاتها معروفة ومحبوبة
أجيال عديدة من سكان موسكو
نرحب بالطلاب والمعلمين
جامعات حضرية مجيدة
الأكاديمية الزراعية سميت باسم
أكاديمية Timiryazevo البيطرية سميت باسم
سكريبين والجامعات والكليات الأخرى
العواصم
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
أعزائي الأصدقاء أكبر تنمو
اقتصاد
هو مجمع مباني العاصمة
تصميم شركات البناء
المعاهد والمكاتب المعمارية
أكثر من تسعمائة ألف شخص يعملون في عام 2016
عام
سلم بناة موسكو أكثر من 8
مليون متر مربع من العقارات
تلقى سكان موسكو 390 مبنى سكني جديد
إحدى وثلاثون مدرسة وروضة أطفال
حوالي 13 مرافق اجتماعية أخرى في
ظهر 90 متجرا جديدا في المدينة
فنادق ومكاتب التسوق والترفيه
المراكز والمباني الصناعية
حجم بناء الطرق في عام 2016
أصبح رقم قياسي واحد
تشغيل 117 كيلومترا جديدة .117
طرق جديدة وخمسة وأربعون جسرا و
الجسور والأنفاق وأهمها
قناع الهدية
قدم البناة يوم المدينة
تم افتتاح دائرة موسكو المركزية
المترو الأرضي الذي بدونه بالفعل
من المستحيل تخيل العاصمة
اليوم في احتفالية الأعمدة العمل
فرق البناء الأكبر
شركات العاصمة شكرا لكم
خلق وتنمية الحبيب
رأس المال
يرحب بكم أصدقائي الأعزاء
رئيس نقابة عمال موسكو
عمال البناء و
صناعة مواد البناء
أليريل
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
اليوم نحن يوم جميل 1 مايو
بناة والفأر tatty شخص ما لك
لا عمود لا ينضب لا ينضب
تحية موسكو وروسيا
تحية على جميع الشغيلة
اليوم أريد أن أقول إن موسكو يتم بناؤها
من خلال الحصول على أجمل ، لدينا الكثير من العمل
سنقوم ببناء عدادات من مستشفى مدرسة الطريق
العيادات والأهم اليوم رئيس البلدية
موسكو
نظمت برنامجًا أكبر
نقل بلطف
بناء منزل في الخمسينيات
تسمى خطة الابتكار الكبيرة
نحن بحاجة إلى بناة جدد أدعوهم
خريجي كلية الخريجين
معاهد لنا لبناء chindo
المنظمات واليوم
مع المطالب والطلب من
أرباب العمل حتى اليوم على كل
كان لدى الشركة اتفاقية جماعية
للحصول على حزمة اجتماعية بحيث
ساعد على العمل المنتج كان
راتب لائق مرتفع
تمام
ما زلت أنتقل إلى كل الوسائل
وسائل الإعلام للصحفيين في
الناس في التلفزيون انهيار نداء للجميع
يعني أظهر رجل العمل حتى ذلك الحين
لقد أظهر له عملًا رائعًا جيدًا
لإظهار سلالة الكلام
شكرا لك عامل
مهندس معماري في الجنة ونحن اصدقاء
اليوم نقف عند القراءة الرائعة
عطلة 1 يوم انتصار أكثر
الانتصارات في عيد الرجال للسلام
حيث انتصار بناة موسكو
[تصفيق]
لكن
في عام 2017 ، تخطط موسكو للبدء
برنامج تجديد واسع النطاق للأحياء
سيكون المبنى المكون من خمسة طوابق
تسوية وهدم
الآلاف من خطافات الأطفال وفي أماكنها
بناء مساكن مريحة جديدة ل
مئات الآلاف من سكان موسكو
النقابات العمالية على يقين من أن هذا العظمة
مهمة على كتف مجمع بناء العاصمة
نتحدث مبنى محشو قديم من خمسة طوابق
بناء مدينة مريحة 21 يوم
للجودة والبناء الحديث
للحد من شروط وضع منازل نوفاك
سكان موسكو
السكن اللائق مع الابتكار
سيستمر بناة kozlovsky الإباحية
تنفيذ برامج المدينة الأخرى
بناء الطرق والتقاطعات رياض الأطفال
المدارس
المستشفيات والعيادات فقط في هذا
سيتم بناء 19 محطة جديدة هذا العام
المترو الذي سيعيشون بجواره أو
يعملون أكثر من 1 مليون مواطن في موسكو
في المستقبل القريب ، سوف يسلم البناة
استغلال
ملعب لوجنيكي الأولمبي الأفضل
الملعب الرئيسي لكرة القدم في العالم
كأس العالم موسكو
موسكو تحت الانشاء
التغييرات تبنى على الضمير
نحن نبني نظامًا حضريًا للناس
هتافات تنمية المدينة القاطرة المعقدة
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
لكن
اليوم تعلن نقابة عمال موسكو
صلابتهم
القتال مع جميع العاملين من أجل لائقة
العمل والعدالة الاجتماعية
اتحاد نقابات عمال موسكو
الوحدة والتضامن
هتافات حقوق الإنسان
مسيرة عيد العمال في أعمدةنا
عمال مدينة موسكو
الرجل العامل أساس مجتمعنا
النقابات العمالية تدعو للعمل اللائق و
من أجل التنمية المستقرة لروسيا
النقابات تطالب بالحد الأدنى للأجور
مستوى واحد تحت الفيديو الحي لك
تحديد مبلغ معاش الدولة
ضمان الحق في لائقة
زيادة أهداف اتحاد الشيخوخة
رواتب الأمن الكامل ومشغول
ضمان وفاء العمل
تشريع
تحيا 1 مايو عمل العالم
يا هلا
[تصفيق]
أعمدة مربعة من الأخصائيين الاجتماعيين
الحماية
الرغبة في أن تكون قريبًا من أولئك الذين يهتمون بالوحدة
ضعيف
هذه القطع تستحق أن يمتلكها الجميع
الأخصائي الاجتماعي الأخدود في حياتك اليومية
العمل يساعد على تحسين الاجتماعية
رفاهية الملايين من سكان موسكو
شكراً لكم في مدينتنا الكبيرة
يصبح أقل قساوة و
لا مبالاة
نظام الضمان الاجتماعي في موسكو
الأفضل في البلاد ومن الأفضل في العالم
أكثر
يتلقى مليون متقاعد
موسكو مدفوعات إضافية لمعاش المدينة
المعيار الاجتماعي فوق أربعة
يستفيد منها مليون شخص
دفع مقابل الإسكان والخدمات المجتمعية أكثر
ثلاثة ونصف مليون من سكان موسكو
لديك الحق في الحرة والتفضيلية
السفر بالمواصلات العامة
موسكو هي موطن لـ 15000 معاق و
المشاركين في الحرب الوطنية العظمى و
80000 عامل أمامي في المنزل يعتنون بالمحاربين القدامى
جيل حياة يستحق من الفائزين
مقاطعة في
الواجب البشري لكل منا في عام 2016
اتخذت موسكو إجراءات إضافية
الدعم الاجتماعي لذوي الاحتياجات الخاصة
سجلات فواتير الخدمات
بغض النظر عن الحجم المستهلك
تلقى عشرات الفئات من سكان موسكو
امتيازات لدفع مساهمات رأس المال
يصلح
موسكو تزداد ودا
أناس معوقين
لم تعد البيئة الحضرية فرقة
عقبات أمام الأشخاص ذوي القدرة المحدودة على الحركة
أرصفة المشاة ومعابر المشاة
الماشية المريحة وعلى الطريق
طرق النقل العام
حافلات منخفضة و
حافلات الترولي
أو ما إذا كانت مباني المدينة مجهزة
نشأ منحدرات مريحة
ثمانية وثمانين بالمائة
الخدمة الاجتماعية في موسكو هي الحماية و
موثوقية العناية وتصل إلى الرف
دولة الرفاهية في روسيا
مدينة موسكو الاجتماعية للنقابة العمالية في موسكو
يتطلب الحفاظ على الفوائد الاجتماعية ل
كل المواطنين المحتاجين
تطوير النماذج المطلوبة
تحسين الخدمات الاجتماعية
مستوى معيشة سكان موسكو
جيلنا لقدامى المحاربين خاصة
الاهتمام والرعاية الخاصة
ظروف لائقة للمعاقين
حياة كريمة
بيئة عبودية بلا حواجز وبراحة
لكل طفل يتيم الحق في تكوين أسرة
الحق في السعادة
عمال الحماية الاجتماعية اللائق
أجور
ألف مبروك لعمال ساتا
وخدمة لنا مع عطلة الربيع و
العمل
يا هلا
لكن
[موسيقى]
يحبون التجارة والمطاعم
الذين يسيرون الآن على طول الميدان الأحمر
تخلصت موسكو من البرية القذرة
الأسواق والأكشاك القديمة المخيفة لكل منها
يتلقى سكان المدينة في السنة مئات جديدة
المتاجر والمرافق الحديثة
الخدمة على مدى السنوات الست الماضية في موسكو
كانت هناك بقع على أكثر من 400 قطعة
التجارة في مساحة إجمالية قدرها 8 ملايين
متر مربع كبير
مراكز التسوق وثلاثة
على تطوير ديناميكي
سكان موسكو في السوق الاستهلاكية
كنت أحب والمعارض عطلة نهاية الأسبوع
بسيط ومريح
مع أسعار لذيذة وطازجة
المنتجات ، فهي مسجلة بحزم في
المناطق السكنية بالعاصمة
متجر تقليد موسكو الجيد
مهرجان عادلة يمر الرائد
السفر في المدينة
أسبوعين من الأسماك مربى موسكو
الخريف الذهبي يجذب الملايين
سكان وضيوف المدينة
والميدان الأحمر يدخلون الجوع
العاملين في شركات النقل
عمود رأس المال برئاسة رئيس مجلس الإدارة
اتحاد تجاري
أسس ونظام النقل بالمدينة
هو مترو موسكو
يستخدمه أكثر من 8 ملايين يوميًا
ركاب
بين أنظمة النقل العالمية
تحتل مترو الأنفاق بثقة
المراكز الرائدة من حيث حجم المرور
كثافة ومستوى حركة المرور
الأمان
كل عام يأتي المترو إلى مناطق جديدة
المدن والاقتراب للمئات
ألف سكان موسكو
وحلقة موسكو المركزية
تم إطلاقه في عام 2016
الأسرع والأكثر راحة والنقل
حلقة في العالم
فريق مترو الانفاق يعيد البناء
ردهة
يتم ترقية المحطات الموجودة
مزارع الحفارات
يجدد الدارجة للتيار
الربيع على خط مترو الانفاق ليس الماوس
عربات مريحة
الجيل الجديد موسكو
نحن فخورون بمترو موسكو
جميل ومريح
المترو في العالم نيابة عن الحامل للطلب
مجموعات مترو موسكو
كلمات